okay um so inria French national
research organization in computer
science and University Paris which is
the largest um university in France and
I'm a professor there as well as a
research director at inria and I have a
joint lab between the two of them and my
group is called exitu for extreme
situated interaction inter situ and we
work with both creative professionals
and um we work with people who are
involved in safety critical systems and
we develop a bunch of new design methods
um I have a book that I just gave a
tutorial about in um at the kai
conference and it's called do it the
design of interactive things and there's
a longer book coming on but it's really
a lot about how to do HCI methods um
from the beginning to the the end um and
the idea is that when we work with
extreme users they push the limits of
interaction which is what we're
interested in and extreme environments
that push the limits of technology so
that's just a quick summary of what we
do um we have four basic research themes
the way we work in France is that we
have a group of Faculty who are all
together so I have five faculty members
in my group at the moment it's gone from
4 to 9 and back down and up and down as
people leave and start their own
research groups but we have a much more
collaborative kind of environment than
um the the sort of typical North
American view we have four different
research themes fundamentals of
interaction is really about the theory
behind um interaction collaboration we
have a large project um projects uh
getting started on collaboration and
we've been doing that for a while
creativity creativity support and human
computer Partnerships and I'm going to
start with the last one today well no
I'm going to start with the first one
today so we we have this thing called
generative
Theory how many of you are working in
human computer interaction I know this
is the HCI seminar but how many are you
actually doing research in that area
Okay so some of you but not all of you
so one of the things that I want to talk
about today is how do you think
about interaction as a key element of
human computer interaction how do we
focus on that as a phenomenon in its own
right and how can we do it in a
generative way how can we be inspired by
Theory that leads us in New Directions
so I'm going to cite this paper that we
just published at Tokai in 2021 um with
my colleagues Michelle Bud who happens
to be over there Susanna buker from the
University of os and me and we want to
think about what does it mean to do
generative
theory if you're doing research and you
should all pay attention to this this
will be useful to you if you're doing a
thesis if you're doing a masters
whatever you're doing think about this
okay if you look at the Natural Sciences
you have two different things that
happen you have formation of theory and
you have empirical observation formation
of theory is often done where you talk
about a theory you test it with an
experiment and then you go back and you
revise your theory and there are a
variety of Sciences Natural Sciences
that work that way so if you're in
physics for example or if you're in
biology you might have the DNA the
double helix or something you say okay
we we have this idea of how the DNA is
structured and we're going to go and do
studies of that and then we're going to
go back and revise it based on our
empirical understanding but there are
also other equally legitimate Sciences
Natural Sciences now that start with
empirical
observation develop Theory and then go
back and test with observation so in
those cases you have things like
astrophysics you have geology you have
um
anthropology those are cases where you
have to look at the real world and you
want to get the richness of the real
world so what's really interesting in
HCI is that we have both of these and
research in
HCI deals with both but there's
something missing all right and what's
missing is the fact that we're dealing
with artifacts and they're dealing with
artifacts that we create ourselves
they're human created artifacts like
this and there are physical properties
to this that I can study but the whole
notion of interaction with technology
and these artifacts that we create is
has to be dealt with in a slightly
different way this is what herb Simon
talks about in The Sciences of the
artificial we are doing science but with
respect to created artifacts they're not
things that exist independently of us
they're things that we're involved with
so now what that means is that we have
in
HCI this Theory empirical observation we
look at users we create theories about
what should should be going good ways of
of Designing things and then we actually
build technology and my argument to you
if you're doing research in HCI is that
you should be doing a complete path you
should be going from Theory through
artifact to observation and back up to
Theory or you should start with
observation go through design and up if
you're just going across the middle
you're in Industry that's fine that's
good you're just not doing research and
there are people who do things like a
lot of AI is going from Theory to
artifact Theory to artifact that's one
kind of thing um there's other people
who go from observation to design it's a
different thing but to do research in
HCI I will argue there will people who
disagree with me but I will argue that
you should do the complete path now
another way of looking at this is that
we have a set of design methods and
again that's what this book is about and
and the other kinds of things that we do
how do we interview people how do we do
a generative walkthr how do we we think
about gathering information from users
and having that influence our designs
and then figuring out whether those
designs
work there's a lot of that in HCI and
there's a lot of that in ux design some
of it more rigorous than others but
basically there's a lot of that what's
often missing is this bit how do we
think about Theory and how does that
inform our design how do we do what we
call generative Theory now if you look
at Theory depends on which discipline
you're coming from I'm a kind of weird
case because I started out as an
experimental psychologist then I spent a
bunch of time with anthropologists and
sociologist I spent a bunch of time in
computer science spent a little time in
management worked in Industry worked in
Academia I've just gone back and forth
and worked with lots of different people
and what I learned in that is that the
shape of theory matters and it's
different so we have descriptive
theories and that's what you do when
you're trying to you see a phenomenon
out there and you want to describe it
and you just want to see if it
matches then there's predictive Theory
which is I can understand what's
happening here but I can predict what
will happen next and there tends to be a
more quantitative element to that but
not always and then there's the notion
of control so if you come from
behaviorism for example you're
controlling human behavior or animal
behavior if you're going to train your
dog you want to control that behavior
that's a different path of theory what
we're talking about is something that's
a little bit orthogonal which is what we
call generative Theory the idea is that
we have theories that we can take from
different places and use them to inform
our design so the idea of a generative
theory of interaction which is what's in
this paper is that we take empirical
theories that exist outside of HCI they
can come from psychology sociology
evolutionary biology you name it but the
problem we generally have is those are
broad theories and the researchers who
create those theories do not create them
with the idea of helping us design
artifacts they just don't it's not their
goal they want to understand the world
they're natural scientists in that sense
or social scientists but their goal is
to understand the phenomenon so what we
need to do is we take the next step we
start creating and developing Concepts
that allow us to articulate what's
relevant from those theories that are
well established but relevant to
HCI and then we create a set of
generative principles these are
actionable principles these are things
that we can look at specifically and say
if I follow that principle I can take
advantage of the knowledge that they've
developed in these other fields and
apply it to my design all right so how
do we do that well we argue that you can
start with existing artifacts and apply
an analytical lens which is to basically
take these analytic iCal principles look
at that particular piece of technology
and figure out whether it's even there
the next thing that you can do so that's
that and it's kind of like is it there
the arrows go slowly and then we can
have a critical lens which we can apply
both to things that exist and also to
new things and here the idea is would
the system be better off if we use this
principle can we put a value judgment on
it and here here basically that can help
us think about improving an existing
system or creating a new one and finally
we have a generative lens which is how
can we use these principles to actually
create something that's new and we find
that this is an extremely powerful way
of creating new technology and new ideas
so in the paper we have three examples
there's instrumental interaction which
is something that we use a lot this is
based on human tool use and Technical
reasoning the one I'm going to talk
about today is human computer
Partnerships which is also another name
for the the the more precise name is
reciprocal co-adaptation but I'll get to
that in a minute and the grounding
theories here are coming out of
evolutionary biology the way species and
animals co-adapt not co-evolution
co-adaptation starts with Darwin has
been elaborated since and the notion of
the adjacent possible which is in a in a
nutshell if you imagine you have a
single cell
organism there's only so much you can do
around that you're not going to go from
a single cell organism to a human being
in one jump doesn't happen but if I have
two of these and they get glommed on
together now I have a multicellular
organism or maybe I have a nucleus
inside and once I have the idea of
multiple ones that I have What's called
the I've made the adjacent possible
bigger so by having these theories I can
build on the set of things that are
possible so that we can make a larger
and larger design space for creating
this okay so that's that's what we're
going to talk about a little bit more
and then uh Susanna's work is much more
on on a larger scale with um community
and common objects based on activity
Theory and artifact ecologies but I'm
going to focus on human computer
Partnerships today so let's think about
what's happening when we're talking to
computers three basic oversimplified
ways of thinking about our relationship
with a computer I can think about me
interacting with this as a tool and
that's basically where we've been
historically in human computer
interaction we think about creating
interactive tools that we can apply and
use to solve different problems for
ourselves and a lot of what we do is
create those tools in this field another
one is the idea that we tell the system
to do something for us we delegate
responsibility and that's where a lot of
of AI these days and a lot of this sort
of notion that the human doesn't have to
do it we're going to delegate it to
somebody else has a lot of implications
in terms of how we think about
interacting and finally there's the
notion of computers as a medium for
communication among people obviously
social media is an example of that and
um this course is a hybrid course and so
some of you are at a distance that
computer is serving as a medium for us
to communicate even though I can't see
you you can see me so when we're dealing
with that I also want to say that we're
not dealing with computers in the
simplest way we can think about how to
place this technology with respect to
the human being it can be something that
you wear it can be something that you
augment in the object itself you can
also augment the environment these are
all different ways that we can create
for doing different styles of
interaction now I'm going to come in and
be rather critical right now about the
way that AI research has being done
today which I object to not because I
don't think that there's some incredible
potential for AI but because the way
that the research is done does not think
enough about the role of the human being
so a lot of AI systems that we see are
changing the way human beings interact
I'll give you an example here so just so
you know Dad's in prison what are you
joking why are you answering your phone
I'm freaking out
okay why not so what's happening as the
person's replying oh wait I mean you
know Dad's interested sorry I was in the
bathroom dad's interested in going to
dinner tomorrow oh you just took five
years off my life thank you to
autocorrect all right the problem that
you get here is not how clever the
algorithm is but the way it's presented
to the user and it's correcting things
for you you've not consciously but sort
of unconsciously delegated the T task of
fix my fix my writing it's fixed it and
it's fixed it in a way that's really
wrong and it's not very smart about
people it doesn't know that that's a
stupid thing there is no such thing as
stupid or not stupid for the on the AI
side and so what's happened is that we
have moved as human beings from being
authors so when I'm speaking to you I
don't have a little thing in my head
saying oh you should say this next you
should say that next the most I've got
is my slides which do prompt me but it's
not some I stay in control but if I'm in
the system is taking control and it's
doing things and I have to actively
shift and say is that the right thing
and I let it go out and and I have just
a very different role okay so when we're
thinking about dealing with AI systems
we have to think about how is that
embedded in real world context how does
that make us interact For Better or For
Worse and it matters what those errors
are it can help us even something that
is 99% right which these are not um if
that 1% of Errors is really going to
take us a huge amount of time to fix
that can be worse than not having it at
all so we should be paying attention not
just to the algorithm but the way it's
embedded in real technology that we
human beings
use now part of the reason for this is
the way that machine learning algorithms
and all of that stuff work there's
basically the idea is that you assume
that there's some kind of ground truth
which may or may not be true you read
your data you calculate it you find some
patterns and then you produce the result
and it's very linear you know I send you
something calculate calculate send it
back but the problem is when you do that
when you think of it that way it's very
tempting as an AI researcher to define
the user's role as either a source of
data to help your algorithm because
you're getting measured on the quality
of your algorithm not not the
interaction the quality of the algorith
so you want better data for your
algorithm please or a source of error to
be resolved so if you look at people in
cryptology or cyber uh cyber security
they're the ones who are talking about
you know the main source of error is the
person in the seat in the chair users as
a source of error really annoying messes
up my algorithm and you can also think
of it as just basically another
component of the machine if you're doing
neural networks and you say great I got
this wonderful neural network and the
human brain is just like that and it's
all it's all one big sheet but none of
those are very productive ways of
thinking about it if you're doing an HCI
perspective you really want to think
about what is the impact on the
user so there's a number of things I
won't go into detail on all of this but
basically there are a lot of issues in
who is creating the data so if you hear
at Stanford are getting a really nice
rapid response to something and you get
your coffee a little bit faster you get
you know reference to that research
article a little better but there's
somebody in Kenya who's working at $2 an
hour who is being forced to be in a
situation where they're dealing with
toxic information is that a good balance
in terms of how we deal with interaction
I mean because there's lots of people
involved in these things at very many
different levels there's other things
where study this a lot it's the um
Boeing 737 Max you may have heard about
this this is the one where they by the
way how many of you think that aircraft
have a lot of AI in the
cockpit put your hands up put your hands
up if you think so because the answer is
no uhuh they don't they really don't
they have to go through a certification
process and so on they're automated they
are not intelligent and when they put in
intelligence like in the mcast system
here this is basically a detector and
you've got the nose of the aircraft
going down and it if it thinks that it's
doing the wrong angle it pulls the nose
down because it thinks you've gone up
too high except that it can be wrong and
Boeing did it so it didn't have any
replications just one source of error
when it went down and you had 14 seconds
the pilot had 14 seconds to fix the
problem and we have two deadly fatal
crashes because of this so this was AI
being introduced with the Assumption
it's correct without telling people it
existed without training
them and it shut down Boeing and those
planes for 2 years and costs I think
what 20 billion in fines massive massive
error so we have to be careful in any
kind of safety critical system about how
we're going to do this now another thing
that I want you to think about as HCI
people who are going to sometimes be
doing AI yourself and sometimes working
with people who do AI is keep in mind
that a different algorithm with the same
interaction can produce the same
result so what matters overall is the
interaction and we have a project on
sustainable Ai and the idea is can we
use less intensive algorithms to get the
same result from the user's point of
view and similarly and very importantly
the same algorithm with a slightly
different interaction can produce
radically different results on the user
classic example um not a classic example
a good example think of ship captains
going into the harbor and they've got a
plot a route into the harbor and they've
got this nice AI system and it comes in
and it tells them a root and it took
them about two weeks before they just
said nope nope nope nope because what
it's doing is deskilling them and they
don't know why it produced that
thing same algorithm same system
different interaction slight
difference now the pilot the captain
excuse me the captain plots the course
first and the system comes back and it
says huh okay that's good but you could
have done this and you could have done
that and then they're evaluating their
own work with respect to other
possibilities and they are thinking
about it now we're upskilling now we're
making them better same algorithm
different interaction interaction
matters okay so keep in mind that a
better intelligent algorithm is neither
necessary
nor sufficient to create a better
intelligence system so we have a large
group of people who are working on
better algorithms more power to them let
them do that we will use the results of
their work but it's critical that we
think about how we interact with those
algorithms otherwise um we create all
kinds of problems okay so there is this
notion of human in the loop here the
idea is the perspective from AI is we're
going to measure success if you go to a
neurops conference you're going to be
measured on how good is your algorithm
did it perform better and what I suggest
we should have is something closer to
computer in the loop where we think
about the measure of success is is the
human being better off and that's a
critical shift it's not necessarily
fundamentally different in terms of that
loop it's still a loop human computer
human computer but it's a different way
of thinking about it the other thing is
that we want to think about interaction
over
time and the fact that people people
change their behavior over time and this
is starting to get to this idea of human
computer Partnerships so there's an
interactive Loop and we're responding
the computer is responding to the user's
actions but the user is also responding
to what the computer does all right now
I want to say one last thing which is
from a research perspective we are
always facing a challenge which is when
we're trying to design a new system we
want to have give the user the maximal
power of expression number of different
ways of doing things and giving them a
powerful way of doing that programming
languages do this really well but
they're not easy to do right now what
you get in contrast is what's on your
phone this has a lot of buttons and
those are easy to push but very low
power of expression so we have this
compromise between power of expression
and simplicity of interaction and I
would argue that that tradeoff is always
there
however as researchers we have a
challenge which is can we move that
curve we can't get rid of the trade-off
but we can move the curve so we can do
things where we keep Simple Things
simple and we allow complex things to be
possible and for this a system that's
this level of
complexity in terms of power of
expression can I make it simpler or can
I add power to something that's that
level of Simplicity we have a number of
different examples of that
in our you can look at our website if
you want to see some examples so how do
we create interactive systems where we
have ai integrated so we want to combine
this idea of the computer is a tool it's
an interactive tool that we can
manipulate and do things with and we
want to think about how we can use those
tools to augment our human capabilities
and we can also take advantage of the
computer as a servant and being able to
take over certain tasks that we won't to
do but the challenge I maintain is to
keep the user in
control so we want to not treat people
as a source of data for the algorithm
but basically consider algorithms as a
source of information to the user and I
don't mean explainability in the
traditional AI sense which is like let
me explain this algorithm to you because
most users don't care it has to be
understandable a source of information
relative to what the user wants to do in
the context of their particular um work
all right so how do we empower users how
do we help them gain skills how do we
help them control the
interaction well I argue that we create
these things that we call human computer
Partnerships and the idea is to take
advantage of the best features of both
because human beings and computers are
very different they have some shared
skills but a lot of very different uh
capabilities so let me think about what
do I mean as a metaphor here for what is
a partnership so if you think about
taking a taxi or an Uber or a lift or
whatever you say I want to go to that
place and say it's been Saturday night
and I'm out drinking and I really
shouldn't drive I want to delegate the
driving to somebody else and so a taxi
lets me do that I can give that control
over to somebody else and I just give
them the address and hope that they'll
get me
there by contrast you have something
where you really enjoy the type of
Transportation you're doing say driving
a motorcycle you've had to learn how to
ride that motorcycle you had to get
certif ified and so on but you really
like going out on a Saturday afternoon
and going through up up to Marin County
or wherever and you're you're riding
around and you're having fun right
that's great you maintain control but is
there something that lets us do both and
I would argue that the metaphor here is
one of a horse so a horse is intelligent
but not the way you're intelligent but
they can get you places and they can
take you home if you're drunk because
they know where home is if you're close
enough um but you can also go jumping
and writing and and do things with that
and the idea is that you can learn both
of you learn to each other you adapt to
each other you learn to get better
riding the horse the horse learns to
interact with you and learns things that
from you and the idea is can we create
Partnerships that have some of these
characteristics where there's some
intelligence that's different from our
own and our own intelligence and we can
learn over time how to control that
interaction okay so now human computer
Partnerships is the marketing term for
what we call reciprocal co-adaptation
and co-adaptation as I mentioned before
comes from evolutionary biology but it's
been applied to how we co-adapt with
technology not with species and
individuals um co- adapting in a well in
evolutionary biology terms so the idea
is that there's four different
relationships you can have I as a user
can adapt to the technology that's there
which means I adapt my behavior I learn
how the system works and if you're in ux
design you're always thinking about oh
create the user experience and it's this
very simplistic kind of okay that's one
thing we'll do we will let people learn
the right
thing um actually I realized that I
should have had the all four so I'm
going to have to say the four and then
the other thing that you can do is you
can adapt the technology you can
appropriate it you can change it you you
can make it different and so if I have
for example this water bottle this is
great oh I'm glad I have a water bottle
um I can use this to drink from but I
could also use it to prop up this book
right I can adapt its properties this is
the notion of affordances which I'm sure
you've all heard about but the idea is
that there are properties in the
physical world that we can take
advantage of and we always use those
properties and manipulate them to make
things happen the way we want to so we
are ad adapting the world around us it's
a phenomenon that happens in you know
evolutionary terms and on local terms
and thing is we can take advantage of
that now that's co-adaptation from the
human perspective interestingly you have
the reverse which is the system can
learn from us as users it can collect
data about us and it can figure out
things about us and it can modify Its
Behavior according to what we do the
other thing it can do is it can
manipulate our Behavior it can adapt us
it can appropriate how we're working and
make us do things now that could be good
we learn stuff it can make us learn
things or it can persuade us to buy
things that we probably shouldn't buy so
there's a whole set of principles from
experimental psychology in particular
behaviorism about how to control human
behavior so there are four different
things going on in reciprocal
co-adaptation and I'm going to now start
showing you some examples all right so
these can be in the simplified version
discoverability discovering how the
system works appropriability how to
change it and expressivity and that goes
both from The Human Side to the system
and the system side to the human all
right so we want to adapt the technology
how it works in context here's a very
simple example so if you think about
this as a phone right this is a very
powerful computer extraordinary comp if
if my my usual example is the computer
that that put a man on the moon is way
more powerful than this right this is an
amazing thing in terms of your hands you
have a huge amount of dexterity I can
take this off maybe I can take this off
can I take this off yes I can look at
that all
right thank you for the water um so I
can sculpt things I can paint I can
write I can do all these different
things but then if you look at the
interface here all I'm doing is touch in
things maybe I swipe I slide I poke at a
menu it's very very very limited
interaction so how could we make
interaction much more Rich well we could
use gestures still very simple relative
to all the things we can do with our
hands but still pretty interesting all
right so why don't we do that well
because we forget we
forget the gestures right we need to
learn them so we have this idea of doing
Progressive feedback what gesture have I
already done discover what the system
understood about what I've already done
and Progressive feed forward which is to
identify what's possible and here in
this example the width of the path shows
me sort of How likely it is we'll see
this in a second so this is an example
if I want to do the question mark
gesture and I don't know what it is I
can pause here and it shows me a number
of different possible paths and I follow
the one that I like um let me just keep
going here um so what's interesting is
that if I'm an expert what I want to do
is do it quickly if I already know it
just don't don't slow me down let me
just do it but if I'm a
novice what I do naturally without
thinking about it is to pause and when I
do that then I'm indicating to the
system hey show me what's um available
here and what's nice about that is it's
both unconscious it does the right thing
when I'm not thinking about it but it
also is something that I can be
conscious of and I can choose to put my
finger down and pause and it will do the
right thing so here we have this example
um this is implemented on a
phone and we have a set of things here
and we can call Alice so this is this
thing here and you notice that it gets
thinner and then disappears so the set
of options disappears as we get further
along in the algorithm and so we just go
here and here's somebody doing it with a
partial here's intermediate you only do
you only pause in the middle of the
gesture and so on I'm running really far
behind so I'm going to just zip I think
I think you've got the idea we have
other examples this is one I just
particularly like um so we studied uh
authors professional writers and we
discovered as part of our work with them
that they like to hear their dialogue
voiced out loud and they actually record
that dialogue and they sometimes go off
and do it they also procrastinate but
they want to do what they call Creative
procrastination so the idea here is very
simple and same principle that you just
saw imagine that this is a there's a
little coaster here called the Sunami my
my my sound friend it's a coaster and it
detects whether the coffee cup is there
or not so the idea is that when I take a
sip of coffee it means I'm taking a
break and so that's a nice time to
launch the audio and it plays The Sounds
in my dialogue so it's a case of and I
can intentionally do it and play a bunch
of them or I can turn it off but it the
idea is that I can maintain my flow of
activity and have these lightweight
little things that are integrated into
the flow of of activity all right now I
said Co adaptation has four principles
the second one is that users can adapt
the technology in different ways for
their own needs what we call
appropriation and here we can do that in
a very explicit way which is like
defining your own commands so here we
have a way of personalizing gestures and
say I didn't like the set of gestures
that I saw before I want to make my own
gestures how would I do that well we
have this compromise that we have to
make there's from the user's perspective
I need to make gestures that I can
easily remember things that make sense
to me and the system has to distinguish
among these different gestures and if
you think about it like if I say here's
a circle and here's a square for me as a
human being I can easily distinguish
that most algorithms cannot but if I
make a line like this or a line like
that the system can easily distinguish
those two but I think of it as just a
line unless I know something about the
algorithm so we have these things we
have to make it clear to the system and
to the user what is an appropriate kind
of gesture so we we put a heat map up
and we have blue means the gesture has
been recognized uh is not as distinct
from some from everything else that's in
the vocabulary and it's a good gesture
to use purple means it's ambiguous and
red means don't stop there because that
gesture is too close to something else
so we have an example
here see if we can yes if you can adjust
the sound a little that's
sorry
okay all right I'm
gonna and
then all right I think I'll stop there
because it's very loud and this is an
example of the gesture going up it ends
in in red that tells me nope that one's
already been taken but if it goes down
and ends in blue that means it's fine
okay there we go and then go back down
right two different gestures okay so
another thing that we can do I'm going
to have to speed up a little bit um
modify your input to create expressive
output so we want to take advantage of
the fact that human beings operate in
different ways so if I'm writing on my
phone and I write a gesture
I gesture type and I write something on
my phone the output will be in exactly
the same font as everybody else's but if
I write handwriting you can see that
there's a lot of Distinction there right
and you can see that this poor kid
basically did all the eyes I will and be
and then thankful for what I have anyway
there's there's information that is in
there because we as human beings are
putting things in a particular way so
the question is how do we capture that
how do we let people do that how do we
add a personal touch so many of you may
know about swipe typing gesture typing
the idea here is that there are very
clever algorithm Schuman XI is the one
who did this um originally and this idea
that if I want to say the word pepper I
can have it go down go up go all the way
around all of those are very cleverly
identified as the same thing so from an
algorithmic point of view it's very very
powerful um however the outcome is
always the same um in each of these
cases you can see those all say the same
word now what we wanted to do is take
advantage of gesture typing which is 40%
faster than tapping on the keys but
allow people to take advantage of the
variation so what's happening in that
algorithm that you just saw is that all
the human variation is thrown away it's
treated as noise and noise is unwanted
there's the right way of doing it the
ground truth this is it any variation is
bad the alternative is to do what we've
done here which is we keep the
recognizer as before but we also
interpret different characteristics of
each gesture we map that onto
characteristics of the um the final
output so we can do R and G and B which
is curviness um inflation and speed
variation we map onto red green and blue
and we can get the entire set of colors
just through gesture we also map it onto
um a font for example we worked with a
um professional choreographer not
choreographer typographer we also work
with choreographers but in this case
typography and this
is I can't turn the sound down but if
you can turn the sound down that would
be oh this is
this
worried
about all right you get the idea
computer not
on okay thank you that's
better feel like I'm being a little
redundant
here so you can see here that she's just
typing she's just gesture typing but
she's controlling through how much
effort she's putting into it the output
and you can see um
here right anyway I will keep going here
you get the idea we can map the
curviness of a
gesture
right I think
anyway there's a variety of different
things we've also implemented this in
something called command board which is
a way of giving you the power of a
command lined um uh interface or
interaction on a soft keyboard and here
we can transform any gesture typed word
into a command that is then
automatically interpreted and what this
lets us do is we can take advantage of
the things that we've talked about
before so this is the octop Focus thing
and this is I'm doing here I start
writing the word brightness and then I
can adjust the brightness it gives me
that this is a font and I can change the
font I can do a marking menu we have a
variety of different ways of basically
using this space here as the keyboard
entry and here is an output space but
we've made that interactive and so we
have this whole way of creating an
interactive space all right I'm going to
not show that another one that we've
done is working with choreographers and
dancers and the idea is that they create
profession they create individual
sketches of what they want to do and
then we have the ability to do something
called notation where we transform their
sketches into interactive elements that
they can manipulate here and and see so
let's see if we can get that working so
here's somebody drawing um and this is
the layout of how they would do this on
the uh
you know on the floor of the of the
stage and then how they they operate
together and then here are some of the
choreographers who are actually showing
their actual work and we can embed video
in there and they can dive in and do
various things so there's lots more to
say about that but I will just keep
going um another thing that we can do is
we can think about teaching machines so
this is basically how do we think about
the role of a data scientist who is
teaching a m a machine's algorithm
the Assumption normally is that they're
experts and they'll just do it and it's
fine and we don't pay attention to that
interaction but it's actually a really
important interaction and when you have
a domain expert who doesn't understand
anything about how algorithms work um
you have to think about what you're
going to teach them so here we have the
idea of helping a novice so it's an
expert in the domain but a novice with
respect to machine learning and how can
they understand the strength and
weaknesses and teach an interactive
classifier so there's these different
types of ambiguity there's aloric which
is ambiguity and noise and epistemic
which is here we'll do that so aloric is
if I'm trying to distinguish a dog and a
cat um if I show a photo with both a dog
and a cat that's noisy and it's it's
ambiguous and that's a different kind of
uncertainty than showing a photo of a
completely different animal which would
be a panda so we have this system what
we're trying to do is get um the get
them to train a classifier to
distinguish between different playing
cards and then show them the different
types of uncertainty and what they do is
they get better at creating training
sets for teaching the algorithm to
distinguish the right kinds of
uncertainty and again I'll go fairly
quickly through that um so there's an
example of showing the training example
if they then Show an example with two
cards that are ambiguous that's a
different kind of uncertainty and
there's an example of putting your hand
in there and that's yet another type of
uncertainty so the idea is thinking
explicitly about what's going on when a
human expert is trying to teach these
algorithms and that's another area that
we need to play with um all right
another one the system adapting to the
user the system learning I'll do this
quickly I hope um so we did work with
graphic designers and all kinds of
different designers working on mood
boards and the the idea is to think
about how you share agency between the
user and the system this was done before
chat GPT and all these things it was
done in 2020 it feels like forever ago
but anyway we have the user in control
which is basically working with curated
sets of images to try to create your own
mood board and in this case we just have
a Cascade of images and they get to
choose different images and look at
different things and so on so that's
basically what you would expect um and
then they're going to create the mood
board on the right the next thing you
can do is have something where the
control is really in the hands of the AI
system um and the agent is looking at
what the user has already done and
suggesting images based on that so this
is based on um a thing where you can see
that they can request more more like
this now what's happening is that they
can search with images they can search
with text it feeds back um a tag Cloud
that says this is what these images are
looking at so we're providing a lot of
information back and forth between the
user the user can use combinations of
words and and um images to search and
then backwards the other way so the last
one is shared control this is the user
and the agent each searching images
together and this is something called
semantic collage this is all part of
something called image sense but this
particular bit as you can see searching
with images because we found that
graphic designers don't like to T type
things they like to search with images
they think visually so we give them the
ability to do that we also give them
words back that they can say more of
this less of that um and they can
identify elements of the images reuse
their search history and so what they're
doing is this Dynamic back and forth
between images and text and what the
system is suggesting and what they're
suggesting back to the system so really
trying to create um a shared controls
shared agency all right the last one is
the system can modify the user's
Behavior so it's teaching or
manipulating the user here we're using
principles that come out of experimental
psychology and the idea here is we
worked with a theater company and they
built this wonderful magnificent um
Christmas display that was up in a
shopping center for a month and we have
a couple of other installations and the
idea is that somebody comes up and they
want to manipulate Santa and make Santa
do a particular move now we want to
teach them to make the right kind of
movement but we don't want to use words
and we won't even tell them that they're
being manipulated so we created this
wonderful machine here and so the
reinforcer is to make that machine move
and I'll show you that in a second and
what we do is we create an interactive
experience with the user where they are
interacting with the little Santa Claus
figure here um and they share control
with the system and the system is
shaping their behavior it's again a
psychology term this is what it looks
like that's making that thing go is
really fun so if you're in a shopping
center and that's the thing kids love
that you get the idea and then here's
Santa just sitting there in the middle
and he just sits there and then if you
walk up to it he'll stand up and he'll
start following what you're doing and
there we
go all right so what we have is a system
where we're using principles from
psychology this is again a gener Theory
so we're using this Theory to help us
control movement so we want to have a
way of indicating to the user that
they're making progress so we have these
three sets of stairs and they figure out
very quickly if Santa mounts the stairs
he can pull a lever which is both a
virtual lever and a physical one and
launch the
machine and if Santa gets bored because
you're not doing something interesting
then he goes back down or he falls
through the floor and the whole thing
stops so the idea idea is that we want
to find the correct movements through
trial and error and we start out by
drawing them in and we mirror their
behavior that gets their attention so if
I go like this Santa does this and he
follows me for up to 30 seconds but at
that point then Santa starts doing
this and now what we're doing is taking
advantage of something called Extinction
Behavior so Santa stops paying attention
and starts looking bored and wants me to
do something else now what happens is if
you stop getting reinforced for doing
something you don't just stop what you
do is you start making lots more
behavior and when you've got lots more
Behavior then we can shape that behavior
this is exactly what happens and so what
we do now is Santa starts rewarding
Behavior so our thing was to try to get
people to make their hands over their
head to do this just random people
coming in off the street and within a
minute and a half we get them doing this
that's our goal and so what he's doing
is reward rewarding Santa is rewarding
successive approximations to the final
Behavior so first any movement is good
then any movement that's above my
shoulders than any movement that's up
here so how does this work well we have
a very simple system we have a skeleton
that is being drawn from a connect and
so this is the connect here this is
mapping whether it's good or bad and
she's doing this she's a little bit
bored she kept coming back day after day
um but she knows that Santa will just
follow her so she that's like not
interesting okay we can do that now
she's doing that but every movement she
makes now once this comes up now she
knows she's got to start figuring out
what kind of movement and we've got it
programmed on the right here and we're
continuing here so we're mapping what
she's doing notice that she's sometimes
got her hands above sometimes not so
it's a little
ambiguous um but then she's getting it's
getting closer getting closer getting
closer she's going to do it ah she's
trying harder and harder harder no she's
trying harder and then it's going to go
come come come
yes go up now she does my favorite thing
which is yes she's doing yeah yeah that
works that works Santa likes that one so
Santa is going to go and and launch the
machine come on Santa go all right so
yes and then that launches the machine
now what's interesting about this and
I'll just show you her cuz it it works
with even really little kids it it's
just very it's a lot of fun even when
her little brother comes up and or
another kid here we
go come on come on come
on
coming and then you see virtual one and
it starts going there we go all right um
so I think I'm going to skip through the
last bit and just say very quickly when
we think about how to deal with um HCI
and AI we need to think about it at
different levels of scale scale and
different levels of time we need to
think about how do we measure human
behavior and how do we take advantage of
different kinds of relationships and
again we can be inspired by evolutionary
biology and the idea of looking at
relationships among species we'll think
about the AI as another species what can
we learn well we can have a long-term
relationship that is positive neutral or
negative and over time that can get
better or worse and we should be
tracking that we should be keeping
um ways of measuring whether these
interactions are positive or negative
and so we want to think of interaction
as a phenomenon that you can study we
want to think about how to measure it
both qualitatively and quantitatively
and think about it in the short medium
and long term um I did this right here
so we want to think about not just
measuring the algorithm's performance we
want to think about the impact on the
user which is not always good and we
want to think about how using the same
algorithm with a different form of
interaction can create a different more
productive and better interaction and
different algorithms can create the same
interaction so we might find simpler and
easier algorithms we don't necessarily
need the most costly one um so we want
to just think about what's our future
are we trying to just use AI to replace
us and we have this wonderful life
envisioned by the movie Wall Pixar of
everybody is just sitting there drinking
their Coke um not really my thing um do
we want to have robots that replace us
or do we want to think about how do we
create intelligence systems that make us
better that turn us into virtuosos that
allow us to do more than we could have
done by ourselves and I'll leave you
there and ask for any questions that you
may
[Applause]
have
questions yes hey uh I really one thank
you so much for this really insightful
presentation and I think it was a great
Counterpoint to some of the things that
we heard at the Wiis
conference it's a different perspective
yes and I think a really important one
so one thank you was a really to see I
wonder if you can talk a little bit
about you know to me a lot of the things
that you're coming down to is about
shared control or mixed initiative
systems and I wonder if you can talk a
little bit about the illusion of control
and sort of the challenges that we face
as designers of these systems in that
people are essentially really good at
making up you know just like these
generative systems are people are also
making up rationale for how these things
work or what's happening and so the
classic yeah anyway so we we we L
anthropomorphize um systems and I
remember way back in the 1980s way back
I've been doing this a long time we
built an intelligent tutor which was not
very intelligent by today's standards I
admit but we had a little clation
character and when he looked like a kid
and spoke in a kid's voice users spoke
in a much simpler way which made it a
whole lot easier for us to interpret
what was going on and it's like the idea
that and that was at the time um what
they call habitable sublanguages but the
idea is that you create these
environments and you can manipulate
people in in in bad ways and good so you
can and I think I don't know I I mean I
think you're right I think we constantly
one of the things that worries me about
these chat-based uh systems is that we
are so programmed to treat that as an
intelligent organism and we expect it to
do things and we trust it to do things
in a particular way and even you guys
who are all very very sophisticated
users relative to the general population
get sucked into some of this right and
the you know person who's just using on
a regular basis is going to be so I I
mean but I I wish I had a magic answer
to how to figure that out but I think
the first thing to do is to be aware
that that's fundamental to it and that
we should not so we we talk um we've
gone to Brussels to talk to the European
commission and we talking um in ACM
policy and doing various things trying
to get people to stop talking about
controlling the algorithm and start
thinking about controlling the
interaction and thinking about what it
is what is our what are we measuring
about that interaction what's the impact
on human beings and how do we legislate
that in some way because I I
think we can't understand it all because
it's super complicated um and highly
context driven but I do think we should
at least be thinking about interaction
as something that is fundamental to what
should be legislated and about yeah so I
completely agree with all of that and
and I think also Sher turkle's recent
work you very interesting I guess I'm
wondering also so that's and again I
love your work here ac across many
different scills I wonder if maybe you
can also talk a little bit about
basically the illusion of control more
in the interaction context so we have
these smart systems for example you
talked a lot about swipe typing where
people may believe that they have agency
you have this Direct interaction where
you're you know manipulating things and
then but you know in the back there's an
Al that pops out something and I'm
wonder if you on a more micro level yeah
on on a more micro level because
actually honestly we mostly work on the
more micro level to be honest um but I
think I I feel like I want to appeal to
my infovis colleagues because there's a
certain element of just what is it that
you reveal to the user about what's
going on and part of the problem is like
so for example
in the octopus example the the width of
the gesture is Getting Thinner and
thinner and then it goes away and that's
revealing to the user in a way that the
user can understand that the algorithm
is saying you're getting further and
further away from that being a
legitimate gesture and so trying to
figure out ways of visualizing that and
it might be auditory visualization it
might be any one of a number of
different um modes but um I think I
think we have to do a lot more of that
and and I just there isn't a lot of
search at the moment in that but I think
you're absolutely right that it's a
really critical area to look at um so
other questions yes um so you argued for
the using the Paradigm of computer in
the loop systems as opposed to the
status human in the right I I'll admit
that that's partly marketing this is
when I talk to my AI colleagues and they
think they're doing nice things for HCI
because they've got human in the loop
and I'm pointing out that no actually do
the other way so yes but fair enough and
then optimizing for rather than
optimizing for the um you know a measure
of the systems accuracy um think about
how um better off the users are yes and
I was wondering and I think you know
there are challenges to that right
course for example because um I don't
think even the measure of what better
off means is not defined or even agreed
on by everybody and I just wanted to ask
your opinion or just so let me give you
examples um that I think help because
you're absolutely right there is no
Universal this is good that's bad that
just isn't going to happen I don't even
know if that would be a good thing if
that were a good if it were possible but
it just isn't but think about the notion
of introducing the feature of like right
and you're in social media system and
and Facebook introduced the idea that I
like that right it has a short-term
positive reinforcing effect so if you
been talking about in Psychology terms
it means means that you know I I feel a
little bit better I get to like
something or people liked my stuff and
that's great but over time it creates an
addictive behavior and people end up
doing things just for the likes and so
on and you can go down a rabbit hole and
we've seen a really large negative
effect of that happening now that was
pretty predictable any any uh
psychologist worth their salt who'd
studied this at all would have predicted
that right so there's stuff that we know
is going to happen and they basically
pleaded ignorance and said oh we're
sorry we didn't didn't occur to us how
would we know um so there is stuff that
we can look at and at least head off or
try to do it the other thing is that we
should be measuring it we shouldn't be
throwing things out into the world and
hoping for the best we should be trying
to at least get some sense based on all
that we know from the social sciences um
about making some predictions and this
why I was talking about different kinds
of theory there's descriptive and
predictive and control Theory and and
and so on we should be taking advantage
of our knowledge to be able to do that I
completely agree that we're not going to
come up with you know the perfect
solution and anytime you put a complex
system out in the world they're going to
be unforeseen things happening and
actually part of the argument behind Co
adaptation is that your users are going
to adapt your technology in ways that
you don't expect my favorite example is
the spreadsheet where people it was
originally designed uh I think was Dan
brickland um one to save time he was at
Harvard and he didn't want to add up
Columns of numbers by hand with pencil
and a large eraser and so he built this
little thing but he cleverly did it in
such a way that he had a structure and
cross referencing and formulas embedded
and then that turned into what if
budgeting which completely changed
industry in terms of how people do
things and then you can do it to run
circuits you can make posters you can do
all kinds of things in a spreadsheet
because it's got a structure that we can
manipulate and adapt and so one of the
questions we face when we're building I
didn't talk about this in this talk but
the generative Theory thing the whole
thing on instrumental interaction and
substrates is about how we build things
that users can manipulate and control
and adapt in different ways so there's
lots to be said I mean it's a very rich
question and there's a lot I don't know
if I've answered it for you but I think
I think we should be thinking about that
and that's the kind of question that HCI
as a field should be asking those
questions so it's good good point
I think we at time um but feel free to
stay on and like ask questions and talk
to speaker let's get wend on
appuse